bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check up votre magazine santé
et bien-être
ce mois ci nous allons à la rencontre
d'une infirmière scolaire au ministre
sans donner en cette période de rentrée
à nous livre quelques conseils pour
éviter les coups nous parlerons ensuite
d'une maladie assez méconnu en france la
drépanocytose une maladie qui touche
plus de 15000 personnes en france mais
tout de suite place aux bonnes
résolutions de la rentrée le mois de
septembre est le moment idéal pour se
mettre au sport afin de garder la forme
et de ne pas se laisser envahir par la
fatigue
florence beaumier coach sportif vous
propose des exercices physiques a
réalisés directement chez vous à votre
domicile vous l'avons rencontrée chez
elle à voisins-le-bretonneux patrick
jacques de dixmude et william elle pour
les images
bonjour florence beaumier alors avant de
vous montrer quelques exercices pouvez
vous nous expliquer les avantages d'une
pratique à domicile bien sûr donc la
première c'est que quand vous avez un
coach qui vient à domicile et bien vous
êtes obligés de pratiquer régulièrement
puisque moi je viens je suis là donc du
coup vous êtes obligés de travailler une
à deux fois par semaine selon la demande
l'autre raison c'est également parce que
moi j'adapte vraiment la séance c'est
personnalisés et puis je sais que je
pratique c'est un sport plaisir donc la
personne passe un bon moment
durant la séance sportive alors vous
allez nous faire une petite
démonstration de quelques exercices bien
sûr quels sont ceux que vous proposeriez
pour quelqu'un qui souhaite garder la
forme et s'entretenir alors on va
travailler sur le stability ball qui est
un gros ballon qu'on peut se procurer
n'importe où un gros ballon jim donc le
premier exercice ce sont des flexions
donc on va prendre le ballon le poser
contre le mur on va leur mettre le
descendre au niveau du dos et on va
venir faire justement des flexions on
appuie contre le ballon vous descendez
bien les fesses à hauteur des genoux et
vous remontez on va faire cet exercice
sous forme de huit répétitions 8 flexion
on va bloquer en bas 8 secondes et
ensuite on fera huit petit en bas à
faire
fois voilà avec des pauses si besoin
entre les séries le deuxième exercice
c'est un exercice pour les abdominaux
donc on va tout simplement venir
s'asseoir sur le ballon les jambes bien
dégagée du ballon on s'avance légèrement
et on vient poser le bas du dos sur le
ballon d'eau bien rond et on vient on
perd des petits balancé de droite à
gauche en rentrant bien le ventre et en
serrant ses abdos on peut faire trois
séries de huit mouvements de droite à
gauche
le troisième exercice on va venir se
placer à plat ventre sur le ballon c'est
un exercice de bennage on a les deux
pieds au sol et les mains également posé
au sol
on va venir lever la jambe droite pour
commencer parfaitement tendu dans
l'alignement du taux et on va lever le
bras gauche le bras opposé
on reste 30 secondes on se relâche et
ensuite on fait la même chose avec la
jambe gauche et le bras droit alors la
rentrée c'est aussi synonyme de stress
de fatigue est-ce que vous auriez des
exercices un peu plus se relaxant à
proposer bien sûr ce sont des exercices
qu'on peut faire en échauffement ou à la
fin d'une séance ou tout simplement pour
se détendre dans la journée donc ce sont
des exercices d'étirement allié à de la
respiration
ils peuvent se faire de beaux à 6 ou
encore allongée on va venir et tirer le
dos donc on inspire honte les bras au
dessus de la tête bien entendu on étire
bien le dos en inspirant et on vient de
descendre les bras en soufflant on peut
faire cet exercice tranquillement à son
rythme trois fois de suite
ensuite on va venir poser la main sur la
hanche et on monte le bras sur le côté
en diagonale en inspire on souffle et on
redescend le bras fait la même chose de
l'autre côté vous avez également la
possibilité de travailler en ouverture
de cage thoracique en place les coudes à
angle droit devant les coudes serrés
contre la taille on inspire on ouvre la
cage thoracique on a
on jeux d'eau on souffle et on referme
les bras on se place en dehors on en
poussant bien les bras devant et en
rentrant la tête puis on déroule
doucement le dos et on le fait trois
fois
alors là bien évidemment ce n'est qu'un
panel d'exercice que vous proposez tout
à fait déjà une séance pourrait devenir
un jour combien de temps alors ce sont
des séances qui durent une heure en
moyenne
et quelle fréquence whitfield est
réalisée pour ce soit un mouvement
efficace
alors si vous souhaitez simplement
maintenir votre condition physique
ce sont des séances d'une heure une fois
par semaine en général les personnes
visent plutôt l'amélioration de leur
condition physique
donc là on va partir sur minimum deux
séances d'une heure par semaine et elle
est votre type de clientèle
et bien en fait je m'adresse
principalement aux jeunes seniors c'est
à dire aux personnes qui ont entre 50 et
70 en gros ce sont des personnes qui
sont surbookés qui n'ont pas le temps ou
pas la motivation se rendre en salle de
remise en forme après j'ai également des
personnes qui ont 20 ans ma cliente la
plus âgée à 90 ans
donc voilà c'est large merci lance deux
premiers pour tous le conseil avec
plaisir vous savez donc ce qu'il vous
reste à faire si vous voulez lire de la
fin
ils peuvent s'attraper tout au long de
l'année
mais les poux sont souvent le casse-tête
des parents en période de rentrée
scolaire
comment les attrape ton comment les
éviter une infirmière scolaire d'une
mesnil saint denis nous livre quelques
conseils
chaque année ils font aussi leur entrée
sur la tête des enfants d'après les
épidémiologistes l'époux prolifèrent
davantage durant les grandes vacances
là où les enfants se mélangent aux
autres et où les parents sont moins
vigilants résultats en début d'année
scolaire il devient la coqueluche des
cours d'école
en général les bains sont pas vraiment
au courant qu'il y ait de leurs enfants
à l'époux et c'est souvent nous qui le
découvrons donc ce qu'il faut bien voir
c'est que c'est assez délicat d'en
informer les familles bien qu'il ne
s'agisse pas d'un manque d'hygiène avoir
des poux est en effet synonyme à tort de
saleté les personnes touchées ressentent
souvent de l'anc
ces petits insectes qui nous démange le
cuir chevelu se transmettent facilement
et passe d'une tête à l'autre par
contact direct
plus rarement il profite aussi d'un
simple échange de bonnets ou des sharp
premiers conseils pour les éviter
à l'aide d'un peigne à dents très fine
faire examiner sa chevelure tous les
jours à la recherche d'éventuels nantes
c'est eux qui deviennent des pouces six
à neuf jours plus tard
alors une lente c'est un petit tu as
donc c'est tout petit ça ressemble à ça
c'est différent d'une pellicule parce
que la pellicule justement se décrochent
du cheveu quand on paye par exemple avec
un pas une fin cet écran du cheveu sa
tombe à une lente reste accroché à la
haute joux est en général pas très loin
de la racine du cheveu
donc la seule façon c'est de le faire
glisser le long du cheveu avec le dos
avec les doigts et c'est comme ça qu'on
reconnaît quoi si vous en trouvez
rendez-vous en pharmacie pour acheter le
traitement qui convient le mieux
à noter que le pou ne peut pas survivre
plus de deux ou trois jours ailleurs que
sur une tête humaine
il ya des shampoings il ya des lotions
il ya des sprays mais surtout ce qu'il
ne faut pas que les parents oublient
c'est qu'il faut traiter aussi les
vêtements les vêtements et la literie
l'idéal est de tout laver en machine à
60 degrés minimum
n'hésitez pas également à renouveler le
traitement jusqu'à disparition complète
de ces petits parasites qui nous
prennent la tête
c'est une maladie qui touche près de 50
millions de personnes dans le monde et
qu'il est pourtant assez méconnu du
grand public
la drépanocytose pour en savoir plus
nous avons rencontré à elancourt la
maman d'un jeune malade ainsi que le
médecin qui le suit depuis sa naissance
un reportage réalisé avec juliette
poussons elodie moines comme les
camarades de son âge mohamadou ici à
gauche aime se détendre devant les
dessins animés
ce qui ne se voit pas c'est que ce petit
talon courtois de cinq ans est atteint
de drépanocytose
un nom qui ne vous dit peut-être rien
mais qui est pourtant la première
maladie génétique en france
elle est causée par des globules rouges
anormaux ceux-ci d'effort mais prennent
la forme de faucille n'arrive plus à
circuler dans les vaisseaux sanguins et
bloque ainsi les échanges d'oxygène tous
les 3 mois - amadou seront ici chez le
docteur charara pour être suivi comme la
plupart des drépanocytaires il subit des
crises de douleurs très intense mais pas
seulement que ces globules rouges vont
avoir une vie plus courte ce qui
explique une anémie chronique année mais
c'est à dire c'est à touba de globules
rouges ce qui explique la fatigue ce qui
explique le soufflement les malades sont
également beaucoup plus sensibles aux
infections car la rate organe qui permet
de filtrer l'eau sans s'épuiser perd son
rôle de défense contre les microbes et
les bactéries résultat moi ma douce
astreints à des médicaments et
antibiotiques tous les jours ce qui lui
permet de vivre presque normalement
au début oui c'était un peu on le
prenait un peu comme un enfant personnel
mais bon maintenant lui c'est lui qui
prouve aux gens que voilà un enfant
comme les autres
moi je les encourage à des mallettes à
la drépanocytose mais vas-y france la
maladie s'exprime de manière très
variable d'une personne à l'autre
mais en ce qui concerne mohamadou le
plus difficile à gérer pour sa maman ce
sont les crises de douleurs ça fait
arriver à n'importe quel moment et à ça
peut durer quelques heures comme que ça
peut durer deux trois jours des fois il
nécessite qu'ils soient hospitalisés
c'est plus des douleurs parce qu'on va
dire au niveau du dos du jaune et du
poignet et ça en plus mais c'est
vraiment à quoi ça fait mal ça fait mal
d'après les chiffres de 2013 en france
la drépanocytose concerne plus de quinze
mille patients et 400 nouveaux nés sont
atteints chaque année identifié grâce au
dépistage néonatal mise en place depuis
c'est justement lors du diagnostic à la
naissance de son fils qu khadidiatou a
appris qu'elle et son mari étaient
porteur sain de la maladie car pour
qu'un enfant ait un risque sur quatre de
la développer il faut que les deux
parents soient porteurs du gène
déficient
la drépanocytose est apparue il ya
quelques millions d'années dans des
zones frappées par le paludisme
l'afrique centrale les antilles l'océan
indien le bassin méditerranéen ou encore
l'amérique du sud
une particularité qui expliquerait
peut-être d'après le docteur charara la
méconnaissance de cette maladie auprès
du grand public
on ne peut pas s'empêcher de poser la
question sur une éventuelle relation
entre la particularité ethnique en fait
de l'atteinte
et c'est ce déficit de connaissance de
cette maladie
aujourd'hui les transfusions sanguines
permettent de traiter la drépanocytose
et dans les cas extrêmes le seul moyens
curatifs reste la greffe de moelle
osseuse le docteur charara crois aussi
beaucoup en la thérapie génique
permettant de remplacer un gène
déficient par un gène sain de quoi
donner de beaux espoirs aux
drépanocytaires
ce numéro de check up touche à sa fin
avant de nous quitter jetons un coup
d'oeil à l'agenda
dimanche 20 septembre c'est la journée
mondiale de lutte contre la maladie
d'alzheimer
l'association france alzheimer yvelines
vous propose différentes actions pour
l'occasion rendez vous sur leur site
internet pour toutes les informations
dimanche 21 septembre toujours
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque
propose une séance de yoga 100%
solitaire à l'orangerie du château de
versailles
comptez 25 euros par personne pour une
séance d'une heure trente
les inscriptions sont à faire en amont
sur leur site internet lundi 6 octobre
c'est la journée nationale des aidants
un après midi dédié à la question est
organisée à la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines rendez-vous de
14h à 16h30
check up c'est terminé merci de votre
attention je vous donne rendez-vous dans
un mois
d'ici là portez vous bien